[Applause]
kawhi leonard he's what it all revolves
around
won a championship with two teams but
look at tht
taking it right away from white that's
what he normally does to the opposition
yeah
kawhi exposed the ball and horton just
reached out slapped it free and picked
it up
lob it in now to mark mark of course
that basketball iq off the chart
he bounces it to the wide open tht on
its way
and down it goes yes sir taylon horton
tucker hustle
on the near side to take control of it
nine to shoot
that's exactly what he does now it's
inside out horton tucker
beautiful play started the hockey assist
gasol and then kcp
and four rebounds off the bench terence
man's done a nice job
horton tucker steps back hits another
shot that's his third field goal
the best i'll leave you two to debate if
he's right
rachel thank you i always think it's
better to let other people say
that you are the best and here comes
leonard as we get under a minute to go
here in the second
pass inside deflected good hands i think
it was horton tucker got a piece of it
down the other end and throws it down
horror tucker
18 first half points
[Applause]
canard lost it morton tucker took it
away
ahead point chuck on the rebound he puts
it back up
horton tucker this 20 points
third straight possession that the
lakers have given a look of a zone
pretty much matching up and containing
again those active hands and tucker
another steal gets inside that layup
won't go he's talking about
i mean this is pre-season teams haven't
been together much
and when they've been together they
haven't played much five on five as
tucker knocks down another shot it's
been a lot of individual workouts
17 minutes number five
luke bernard fourth
[Music]
40 years old now he played last time he
played was march of
2019
[Applause]
[Music]
tucker banks it in wouldn't be special
but he knows
a long way to go before he thinks about
coming back
blocking foul horton tucker banks it in
a little english off the glass
way he's playing he is not playing like
a pre-season game he's playing like he's
on a mission
you're going to know about him because
he's going to start playing and getting
minutes
and seeing that he can really play on a
championship caliber team
it wasn't just westbrook for wall they
didn't get better with that but they
now have the ability to play with size
on the floor
so they could be dangerous